et avec moi sur ce plateau à présent
antoine mariotti bonjour antoine jour
pauline et vous salomé zourabichvili
bonjour à vous bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes la présidente de la
géorgie un pays qui ne connaît que trop
bien les méthodes du kremlin oui bonjour
salomé zourabichvili vous méconnaissez
en effet que trop bien ces méthodes du
kremlin comme le disait paulina
l'instant parce que votre pays la
géorgie en a subi en subit toujours les
conséquences on se rappelle évidemment
de la guerre de 2008 la géorgie a perdu
20 % de son territoire avec cette
intervention russe perdue de région lab
ghazi et l'ossétie du sud c'est la
quatrième fois d'ailleurs dans votre
histoire que vous connaissez ce genre de
choses avec la russie c'est un petit peu
comme en ukraine avec donetsk et l'avion
la russie qui se sent menacé
alors avant d'en venir à l'actualité
évidemment avec tout ce qui se passe en
ukraine il y aujourd'hui des dizaines de
milliers de soldats russes qui sont
présents donc en abkhazie et en ossétie
du sud vous n'avez pas la capacité
militaire de reprendre ces territoires
on voit bien que d'une manière générale
la communauté internationale ne
reconnaît pas assez indépendance c'est
sécession de ces deux régions mais en
même temps presque personne n'est prêt à
vous aider à les récupérer est ce que
quelque part
poussé par les faits vous avez un peu
renoncé à ces deux régions la revue la
géorgie n'y renoncera jamais non on n'a
pas renoncé à ces deux régions on a
renoncé
formellement à l' usage de la force pour
les récupérer parce que ce rapport de
force tout à fait illégal ne laisse pas
d'autre espoir que éventuellement
d'avoir une occupation encore plus
importante par la russie mais ça ne veut
pas dire renoncer et il y a deux échecs
majeurs en tout cas de la russie dans
dans cette relation l'unss et que
effectivement ces territoires occupés
ils sont occupés et personne ne les a
reconnus sauf des clients de moscou deux
ou trois mais en réalité la communauté
internationale donc n'a pas reconnu et
continue à reconnaître la géorgie dans
ses frontières et par ailleurs la
géorgie
n'a pas changé n'a pas changé
perspective n'a pas changé son
orientation et continue à avancer et
j'espère que l'avancé va se précipiter
vers son intégration dans l'union
européenne et dans le temps donc ça
c'est un échec majeur parce que le but
en réalité ce n'est pas d'éviter une
menace comme le dit trop le kremlin ni
en ukraine ni en géorgie il n'y a aucune
menace vis-à-vis de la russie le but
c'est de remettre ces ces ex républiques
soviétiques qui sont je l'espère de
futurs république européenne de les
remettre sous le joug de l'art 6 et l
ambition impériale du kremlin de tout
temps mais ce n'est pas un objectif qui
sera atteint alors justement ces
derniers jours on entend de plus en plus
depuis le début de l'invasion de
l'ukraine que la menace russe pourrait
ne pas s'arrêter à l'ukraine que la
moldavie ou la géorgie pourrait
potentiellement être ciblés par la
russie est ce que en tant que pays vous
vous sentez menacés ce que vous
personnellement vous sentez menacés que
vous pourriez vous retrouver dans une
situation similaire à celle de votre
homologue ukrainien le président et
lenski je pense que nous sommes tous
menacés et que
l'europe a trop longtemps pensé que la
menace russe s'était pas pour elle il je
crois que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ce
sursaut européen cette unité européenne
c'est probablement le fait de réaliser
qu'on ne peut pas laisser il ya eu
d'autres précédents il ya quelques
dizaines d'années dans le siècle dernier
on ne peut pas laisser un régime
totalitaire dictatorial avancer sans
réagir parce qu'à un moment donné il n'y
a pas d'arrêt et que personne ne sait
qui sera le prochain menacé vous avez
salomé zourabichvili rencontré hier à
l'élysée le président macron il vous a
assuré de son soutien la géorgie n'est
ni membre de l'otan a ni membre de
l'union européenne à ce jour pensez vous
que la france ou quelqu'un d'autre
viendra à votre secours si vladimir
poutine avait eu l'idée de reprendre là
où il s'était arrêté
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle à votre
secours on sait que en ukraine aussi il
n'ya pas une intervention militaire des
pays européens ni les états unis parce
que nous ne sommes pas dans le temps
parce que l'ukraine n'est pas dans le
temps ce doux 7h quête de sécurité de la
géorgie de l'ukraine de la moldavie
parce que nous savons que tant qu'on
n'est pas sous la protection de
l'article 5 on n'est pas sous cette
forme de protection en revanche ce que
je suis venu chercher c'est l'attention
c'est le soutient celui qui
manifestaient aujourd'hui envers
l'ukraine et qui est le pas
supplémentaire le pape politique
supplémentaire en direction de l'union
européenne pour sentir comme la dire sur
la fan zeng nian que nous sommes des
vôtres et ce soutien là il est très
important il est celui qui est
politiquement décisif et celui qu'attend
la population géorgienne la population
ukrainienne aujourd'hui sous les bombes
c'est cela qui est fondamental
aujourd'hui alors justement vous avez
rencontré emmanuel macron hier mais
aujourd'hui vous allez rencontrer à
bruxelles charles michel et ursula von
der leyen c'est une sorte d'opération
commando pour que surtout on n'oublie
pas la géorgie malgré tout ce qui se
passe en ukraine c'est pas mal gré c'est
il est clair que la priorité aujourd'hui
c'est l'ukraine parce que je ne suis pas
sous les bombes
mais dans cette priorité il est très
important de ne pas faire apparaître des
maillons faibles que poutine ne puisse
pas se dire bah tiens en ukraine ça se
passe mal pour moi donc essayons un
endroit qui est plus facile qui serait
la moldavie ou la géorgie donc c'est
effectivement revenir sur la carte de
façon très pressante mais c'est aussi
en quelque sorte faire notre déclaration
alors je n'ai pas signé
l'acte de demande d'adhésion comme l'a
fait très publiquement zelensky et c'est
très très bien il y a aujourd'hui une
fenêtre d'opportunité qui est la prise
de conscience par les européens que pour
ces pays il faut comme l'a dit le seul à
leur ouvrir les bras ça veut dire une
autre forme
d'intégration qui ne soit pas cette
forme technologique technique
progressive le fermer les chapitres
d'accession et peut-être une forme plus
politique peut-être pas immédiate mais
apa politique un signal politique très
clair pour tout le monde est-ce que je
force un peu le trait évidemment mais ce
qui n'a pas un peu tout perdu ces
derniers jours vladimir poutine on voit
que l'europe ou en tout cas l'union
européenne n'a jamais été aussi unis
dans une crise on voit que l'otan
finalement sort de son statut de mort
cérébrale pour reprendre les mots
employés il n'y a pas si longtemps à
part emmanuel macron vladimir poutine
arrive même à pousser un pays comme
l'allemagne particulièrement rétif à la
chose militaire a non seulement livré
des armes létales ce qui est quand même
extrêmement rare chez chez les allemands
mais aussi à augmenter son budget de
l'armée on sait quand on est membre de
l'otan il faut rapidement de
téléspectateurs ont doivent consacrer 2
pour ce sens que iv l'avait jamais à la
défense donald trump avait largement
essayer de divine here et puis on voit
bien que il ya des sanctions de plus en
plus fortes et des ruptures tous niveaux
culturelles sportives et c est ce qu il
va atteindre une sorte de point de non
retour où il ne pourra plus finalement
réintégré entre guillemets le carnation
comme on dit un peu facilement en tout
cas il a tout faux c'est à dire qu'il a
tous mal calculée tous ces calculs
politico stratégiques n'ont pas été ce
qu'il pensait y compris chez lui je
pense pas qu'ils avaient imaginé qu'il
puisse y avoir il ya déjà eu des
manifestations à saint pétersbourg qui
est toujours connue comme la ville
plus dissidente en quelque sorte mais
pas dans 25 villes russes le nombre
d'arrestations
est un signe qu' il ya quelque chose qui
se passe aussi dans la population russe
et qui est sans doute lié au fait que
effectivement vis-à-vis des ukrainiens
ils ont un sentiment de proximité
différent de ce qu'ils avaient vis-à-vis
des tchétchènes qu'ils ont massacrés ou
vis-à-vis de la géorgie donc là il y à
un élément supplémentaire et puis il
faut regarder le reste du monde cet
isolement s'est pas seulement vis-à-vis
l'union européenne s'est pas seulement
vis-à-vis de la russie même la chine
ne soutient pas
complètement et sans ciller je dirais
cette espèce d'invasion humainement
inacceptable
erdogan a pris des mesures en mer noire
alors qu'ils sont dans un dialogue à ses
proches
donc tout ça est à observer et je pense
que non seulement l'impression que l'on
a c'est que poutine est très isolé à
l'intérieur que c'est lui qui décide
qu'il a pas beaucoup de conseillers qui
l'écoutent mais il est de plus en plus
isolés à l'extérieur
etc ces gestes qui sont l'isolément y
compris dans le domaine sportif tout ça
c'est c'est très
pressant et ça va être très compris par
la population russe elle-même à la
population russe ont voté plusieurs
milliers d'arrestations mais s'engagera
je l'estimé vous parler du reste du
monde et notamment des occidentaux est
ce que finalement on n'a pas un peu
laissé faire poutine tout ces dernières
années il y a eu évidemment parlé tout à
l'heure de votre pays la guerre en
géorgie en 2008 mais il ya eu la crimée
il y a eu évidemment le dombass il y a
eu tous ces empoisonnements d'opposants
script à la vanille l'assassinât de
boris nemtsov opposant numéro un au
kremlin il ya toujours eu des des
condamnations verbales diplomatiques il
ya eu régulièrement des sanctions mais
jamais suffisamment forte pour
l'empêcher d'agir et le dissuader de
continuer est-ce qu'on a une
responsabilité nous européens nous
occidentaux dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ukraine je pense que oui
dans la mesure où il ya eu pendant des
années non seulement l'absence de
d'union d'unité de fermeté
mais il ya eu de l'apaisement permanent
ces mesures d'apaisement ne pas irriter
ne pas provoquer les mots qu'on entend
encore aujourd'hui par certains
dirigeants politiques ne pas provoquer
personne n'a jamais provoqué poutine
aucun de ses voisins n'a jamais menacé
la russie c'est la russie qui par ses
actions transforme ses voisins qui
pourraient être des voisins en remuant
fait pour dissuader on n'a rien fait
pour le dissuader on a tout fait pour
l'apaiser mais ce ne sont pas les
dirigeants de cette
de ce caractère là ne se laisse pas
apaisé ça ne fait que les encourager en
quelques mois si vous le voulez bien car
le temps nous manque malheureusement
les images de deux convois militaires
russes qui avancent vers kiev vous avez
eu je crois le président hélène ce qui
est au téléphone avec quel état d'esprit
l'avez vous trouvé et quel est votre
degré d'inquiétude par rapport à la
situation des civils notamment des
grains l'inquiétude et les extrêmes
puisque de tous côtés on entend parler
de bombes de classe très bon ben je
crois que c'est les bombes à sous
munitions si je ne me trompe pas
edit la taxe sur les immeubles civils
sur les maternités en fait tout ce que
l'on entend fonder une provocation
extrême moi j'ai trouvé zelensky tout
aussi faire mais tout aussi déterminé
tout en acceptant la négociation moi ce
que je trouve très important de dire
c'est que dans cette situation c'est lui
et lui seul qui doit décider à quel
moment et qu'elle forme de compromis il
peut accepter les intérêts ukrainiens
c'est lui qu'il représente il ne
faudrait pas qu'il soit sous pression
d'accepter une forme de compromis qui
serait au delà de ce qu'il pense
raisonnable pour les intérêts de son
pays donc faisons lui confiance
il a mérité la confiance de sa
population et de ses partenaires merci
beaucoup merci salomé zourabichvili
d'être revenu ce matin sur le plateau de
france 24 présidente de la géorgie on va
vous laisser partir du côté de bruxelles
merci beaucoup antoine antoine mariotti
pour cet entretien on se retrouve juste
après la pause pour la suite de paris
direct à tous
[Musique]